bienvenidos a mi presentación de álgebra
ecuación de una recta y bueno pues
empecemos lo que quiero saber después la
ecuación de una recta que pasa por los
siguientes puntos por el punto 12 y
también me voy a tomar el punto 3.4 y
bueno yo lo que quiero es la ecuación de
la recta que pasa por estos dos puntos
así que lo primero que quiero que
hagamos es que grafique mos estos dos
puntos para ver en dónde estamos así que
dibujemos aquí los dos ejes el eje x y
elegiré y vamos a dibujar aquí sus
escalas tengo 1 2 3 4 5 para arriba y 1
2 3 4 5 para la derecha este es el eje x
este es el eje y mi primer punto es el
punto 12 perfecto es justo este de aquí
y el otro es el 34 así que lo voy a
poner justo por aquí aquí estamos en 4 y
ahora me voy a tomar una recta que pase
por estos dos puntos así que déjame
dibujarla y justo lo que queremos
nosotros es la ecuación de esta recta
pero lo que sabemos es que la forma de
la ecuación de una recta es
es igual a mx + b donde m es la
pendiente y donde ven es la intersección
con el eje de las 10
así que m es la pendiente y ve la
intersección con el eje de leyes puede
ordenar el origen la intersección con el
eje y si yo quiero encontrar la ecuación
de esta recta lo que necesito saber es
cuál es su pendiente y cuál es su
intersección con el eje de las 10 y
bueno lo podríamos ser tal vez de una
manera gráfica pero para no perdernos y
hacerlo de manera muy exacta lo voy a
hacer de una forma matemática entonces
lo primero que necesitamos es la
pendiente y bueno recuerda que la
pendiente habíamos dicho que es lo mismo
que ascender entre avanzar entonces
déjame ponerlo aquí ascender entre
avanzar a avanzar lo que ascendemos
entre lo que avanzamos es decir lo que
nos movemos hacia arriba o hacia abajo a
comparación de lo que nos movemos hacia
la derecha o hacia la izquierda el
ascender entre el avanzar o dicho de
otra manera
el cambio en james entre el cambio en x
muy bien y para esto lo que hay que
hacer primero es el cambio en tiempo y
el cambio en james es cuánto nos movimos
en estos dos puntos es decir 4 menos 24
menos 2 es el cambio en 10 porque son
los dos valores que tengo de james y
abajo nos va a quedar el cambio en x es
decir cuánto estamos cambiando en
nuestros valores de xy para esto tengo
dos valores de x 3 y 1 entonces me voy a
tomar la diferencia de 3 -1 y bueno 4 -
2 es 23 menos uno es 2 y por lo tanto 2
entre 2 es 1
esto quiere decir que mi pendiente tiene
el valor de 1 mi pendiente vale 1
es decir que por cada unidad que yo no
mueva hacia la derecha no voy a mover
una misma unidad hacia arriba y eso
tiene todo el sentido del mundo y si yo
me muevo una unidad hacia la izquierda
entonces no voy a mover una unidad hacia
abajo y aquí se nota luego luego si yo
me muevo una unidad hacia la izquierda
una unidad hacia abajo perfecto ahora
una vez que ya tenemos la pendiente lo
que nos hace falta saber es la
intersección con el eje de las guías o
la ordenada al origen y para esto lo que
voy a hacer es poner el dato que ya sé
ya sé que muy pendiente vale 1 y bueno
sustituyendo esta información me queda
que es igual a 1 por x más bien o lo que
es lo mismo y es igual a x + b y ahora
lo que necesito es encontrar la vez y
como encuentro a la vez pues bueno lo
que voy a hacer es sustituir uno de
estos dos puntos o este oeste y bueno
para hacer las cosas más fáciles pero
sin distinto voy a utilizar el punto 1 y
el punto 1 me dice que cuando x vale 1 y
llevarle 2 entonces vamos a sustituirlo
en esta ecuación de la recta que tengo
aquí lleva de 2 x vale 1 cuando x vale 1
más bien y entonces vamos a despejar a
ver para que con esto obtengamos su
valor entonces voy a restar uno de ambos
lados de la ecuación estos dos se van y
me queda que ven es igual a 2 - 1 lo
cual es uno perfecto b vale 1 y bueno ya
tengo ahí media tengo a ver por lo tanto
ya tengo la ecuación de esta recta esta
recta tiene como ecuación y es igual a 1
por x lo cual es x + d pero b vale 1 y
ya está tenemos aquí la ecuación de la
recta que pasa por dos puntos y ya quedó
perfecto así que para repasar mejor
vamos a hacer otro ejercicio y no voy a
tomar un ejercicio muy parecido me voy a
tomar la recta que pasa por los puntos
menos 35 y 26 y yo lo que quiero
encontrar es la ecuación de la recta que
pasa por estos dos puntos así que en
primer lugar saquemos la pendiente la
pendiente es igual al cambio el diente
del cambio en x es decir me voy a tomar
la diferencia en los valores de menos 65
entre 2 - menos 3 ojo ten mucho cuidado
con todos los valores de los signos aquí
está la clave y me quedan menos 65 es
menos 11
bajo voy a tener 2 - menos 3 lo cual es
menos por menos más me queda dos más
tres lo cual es 5 la pendiente de esta
recta es menos 11 quintos oye y no te
has preguntado qué es lo que pasa si yo
pongo los puntos al revés es decir si
primero me tomo el 5 y después que al
menos 6 me quedarían 5 menos menos 6
entre primero éste me quedaría menos 3 -
2 - 3 - 2 y vamos a llegar a lo mismo
pues vamos a ver 5 más 6 porque recuerda
que menos por menos es más me queda 11 y
abajo menos 3 - 2 es menos 511 entre
menos 5 lo cual es menos 11 quintos es
perfecto llegamos a lo mismo entonces lo
que te quería decir no importa el orden
en el que toma es la diferencia de los
puntos pues si lo haces con mucho
cuidado vas a llegar a la misma
pendiente y bueno yo sé que todas las
ecuaciones de las rectas se ven como ye
es igual a mx más b
entonces lo que necesitamos ver para
sacar a b voy a sustituir a m en esta
ecuación y me queda que james es igual a
menos 11 quintos por x
más ve por qué me vale menos once
quintos y bueno ahora para acabar este
ejercicio lo que necesito es ver y para
obtener a ver lo que voy a hacer es
utilizar uno de estos dos puntos y
sustituirlo en esta ecuación que ya
tengo de esta recta y dice cuando
llévale 5x vale menos 3 entonces me
quedarían 5 es igual a menos 11 quintos
por menos 3 más ven ya que despejará
bien de aquí voy a obtener que 5 es
igual a menos por menos más 11 por 333
33 quintos más ven y ahora voy a restar
treinta y tres quintos de ambos lados de
la ecuación b es igual a 5 menos treinta
y tres quintos y ya lo único que tengo
que hacer es esta operación que tengo
aquí en fracciones y cuantos esto 5 % 25
entonces me quedaría 25 menos 33 entre 5
y 25 menos 33 es lo mismo que menos 8
negativo bueno 33 menos 25 es 8 y si yo
me tomo que éste es más grande entonces
me queda menos ocho quintos perfecto me
vale menos ocho quintos por lo tanto ya
sé que la ecuación de la red
qué pasa por estos dos puntos tiene la
forma y es igual a la pendiente que es
menos 11 quintos por x más ven pero ve
vale menos ocho quintos y ya está ya
tengo aquí la ecuación de esta recta que
pasa por los dos puntos y entonces hemos
acabado